what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
Samurai Jack was one of the greatest
shows ever in the history of television
and there'll be no arguing that point
I love Samurai Jack still Lamar I loved
Phil Lamarr Samurai Jack
okay jeers do the Samurai Jack was not
originally a coloring book not that I
know of it was basically just a TV show
so for those of the guys who were
curious as to how we got here in this
comic book ah you really just got to
watch seasons one before I mean there's
no coming books to run over and I'm
coming to explain so it's not you know
cartoon shows explained I'd be a great
idea for a youtube channel but with
regards to this cover look it does serve
a purpose so for those of you guys who
are new to the concept of Samurai Jack
this was basically a show that launched
a 2001 and ran the 2004 I think it was
and it was really just this idea of a
time-displaced Samurai there was a
steamin entity named aku and basically
kind of thrust rush Samurai Jack into
the future work who had taken over the
world the reason being because you know
Samurai Jack just kept fighting against
the coup all the time but the idea was a
samurai traction original name was never
given instead he just showed up in the
future one day then the people just sort
of call him jack and then he just had
this awesome theme song intro Samurai
Jack but the idea is that he was always
trying to find a way to get back home
the problem is that by the time the show
came to an end in 2004 it was it really
kind of gone off the rails and I mean
The Scotsman was cool but the issue is
that it seemed like it kind of got off
the rails so I think that Cartoon
Network really just kind of said alright
it's time to get while the getting's
good
they just canceled the show and there
was no real conclusion that's one of the
reasons why season 5 it's so hyped
because people are just like hopefully
we'll finally get a conclusion to the
show or at the very least just kind of
take a nostalgia trip which I love going
on two sound trips to the 90s and 2000
but with regards to the comic book
series what this did is it filled in the
holes between season four and season
five so this is not like our Walking
Dead videos or Walking Dead videos for
all of hit the purposes contained
spoilers because while they wouldn't
necessarily copy the comics in their
entirety
they would copy a lot of stuff from the
con
but with Samurai Jack there's no
spoilers here because as far as I'm
aware the show just kind of picks up
from these comics but these comments
were written by Jim Zod they were
released by IDW and the idea was just
kind of fill in the gaps so what this
does is it sort of just jumps in with
with Jack's chasing after or trying to
locate a guy by the name of Sol de Sol
the sphere now so let's see as far as
I'm aware is a new creation here this is
one of the reasons why Samurai Jack was
so cool is because it took on this very
children show slash adult show blend
which is what made it so cool like you
would go through I don't have like the
narrative you know the narrative of a
children's show like once upon a time
you know and it's like shut up I'm
talking it was really cool the way it
all kind of came together but but what
is happening here of course is soulless
fear says he already knows who Samurai
Jack is he knows his mission is to get
back to the past defeat a Koosh that a
coup could never take over the future
you know all that kind of good stuff the
problem is solo series like look even if
I gave you the information that you
wanted like the Scorpions of the of the
scorching sands would kill you will say
why Jack's but that's not a problem
because I already took them out well
then this is when so the sphere switches
over from being like this I am sold is
here to be like ah right dude let's see
what you got it's really kind of funny
that's one of the things I like about it
is because it's kind of like you know
it's you first encounter characters and
they have like this trope you know like
this mist you know I am so the seer you
know you must believe me and I have
powers you know and then suddenly like
the illusion is immediately seen through
and so solo series like okay fine let's
just get down to brass tacks it's cool
to see that happen that's one of the
reasons why I love it so much but what
soul the seer says is that in the early
days of the universe's creation there
was something that was referred to
called the rope of eons and what the
group of eons did is it basically
connected the past to the future
it was basically a way for a person to
transition from one place to the next so
you can literally harness the rope and
you can walk back and forth through time
the problem with this is that when aku
was able to really take over everything
in the end he basically shredded the
robe of eons because he mastered the
ability to time travel he mastered the
ability to manipulate the fabric of time
itself and didn't want anybody else to
have that power and so the cool thing is
that what's oldest Peter says if you're
basically gonna have to go on a mission
to find these little threads of the Rope
of eons you're literally going to have
to
recreate the rope again and then when
that happens you can use that rope to
send yourself back through time and so
what happens we basically says look go
out to this direction over here just
keep walking and you'll come across the
first you know little thread as you get
to basically a gladiatorial arena the
problem with this is Samurai Jack walks
up to the gladiatorial entrance be the
Warriors entrance to the arena which is
actually a trap that's what they're
doing here they're basically laying
traps in the ground and they're calling
them warriors entrances and it's like
hey man you came to the Warriors
entrance and that's what he says like
you know this guy's reason is the one
who's kind of running a gladiatorial
ring and Jack's response is like well
look dude I did not intend to walk
through the Warriors entrance I'll just
be on my way and reasons like nah man
the Warriors entrances the Warriors
entrance you got to fight Jack's like
what's a trap he was like well I mean
you know Tomatoes motto what you call a
trap I call it interest and it is its
light some of the reasons why it works
so well because these funny little a
little scenario if these little back and
forth between the different characters
but the other thing here is we also get
a lot of the the down-home element of
Samurai Jack and this is really where
the story just kind of hit its stride
because Samurai Jack was nothing if not
a show it just made fun of tropes I mean
you got like artistic Club of fire the
guys got a club he just clarifies people
I mean if they have names they have
these little nicknames that are based on
tropes you know there's a guy oh the
butt blaster and different things like
that it's designed it makes fun of
things but it resonates so well because
the story itself is told in such a good
way so it's not like it's a parody you
know I mean it's not like it's absolute
jargon and absolute nonsense it's a cool
great ongoing story they grab your
little tropes in from here and they're
kind of pokes fun it like these
superhero stories and these old samurai
stories you know I mean I guess Kurosawa
themes and so on and so forth but the
idea is that of course dreesen offers
Jack this actually says look you have to
fight in order to escape the
gladiatorial arena you can find all
these guys you have to find all these
guys which one do you want to fly first
now of course this is the other cool
thing is because Jack sits down he's
like well I mean I could fight them all
one by one but if I do I'll be exhausted
by the last so he's like I'll just fight
Amala one so that's the cool thing
that's why the show watch is because it
was always action it was always moving
fast things were always cool but the
animation was really funky and I really
liked the way it looked it was really
wild look at in terms of how the
how the show was drawn it was really
like a great throwback to the old
scooby-doo cartoons where was always
doing the same background just moving
back and forth all the time but it was
still cool to see you know how
everything how everything unfolded but
the idea is of course he's able to take
them all on a traditional you know
Samurai Jack stuff but unfortunately all
these different people in the
gladiatorial arena I'm really kind of
like you know rally him it's like the
ponytail is only with a colony on that
kind of stay but of course he ends up
claiming his victory over overed reasons
and then he grabs this one little threat
of the robe of eons and begins the
process of continuing on his journey and
that's why I thought was just kind of
cool is because the comics I mean you do
have like story arcs words like
six-issue a six-issue story arc and it
only ran for 24 25 issues it was only 20
or something like that it didn't run
very long but the way the gems up did
this was so cool because it was
basically each comic being an episode of
the show and so it was cool because you
could do each one of these comics in and
of themselves and each one just follows
like a different adventure it just
follows a different story we're Samurai
Jack goes against a different group of
people each time or sometimes it might
stretch over a couple group of people
basically each comic is in and of itself
its own story so it's really cool to see
it all come together but if you guys are
new here to come this explain make sure
you get the sub button to become part of
the Rob or if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and to
be honest I'm just kind of testing the
waters with the Samurai Jack
video right now I'm just curious I mean
if you guys want to see more we can do
more of its 20 so I mean we do one video
a week you know and just cover each
individual comic it's cool the way some
yeah I like it I loved the Samurai Jack
story um this will be one of the videos
series that I'll do that's completely
for you guys I mean I love Samurai Jack
and I've already read all these stories
so I mean I've got mine already went to
comiXology and already read them all but
if you guys want to see them I'll cover
I mean you know that's something you
guys are interested in I mean it's to be
purely your thing so let me know down in
the comment section if you guys want to
see more Samurai Jack stuff and yeah I
will catch you all later please
[Music]